[Music]
so I'm at the airport right now if you
haven't noticed this is probably gonna
be the best flight of my life and it's
also hopefully gonna be the people who
are on board their best flight ever I
partnered with Nintendo and Southwest to
give everybody onboard and in ten to
three GS and a copy of the new Super
Mario maker for 3ds this is gonna be so
much fun
I'm so excited
[Applause]
okay let's board oh by the way uh you
guys remember Adam Adam oh I'm here I
just looked like this is gonna be
incredible
yes turn your 3d guess on we need this
your pass let's go let's go cheap ass
we're about 40 guys hello everyone
Sami Mario let me introduce you to a
princess oh that's a game vintage but an
Ethernet the princess
her name is iJustine hello you guys hear
me okay this is cool I've never used
before so I'm Justine and I make youtube
videos and I'm a huge to tend to bear
special announcement for you guys
everybody on this plane thanks to
Southwest miss endo
he's all getting
Nintendo 3ds XL who's a tender fan
[Applause]
[Music]
like that I would against waters phew
you
somebody if I was on this flight I was
white when I am on this plate but if I
was sitting here and
the surprises i got i got aboard
[Music]
all right what is your agenda huncles
my new best friend
back
[Music]
okay so there is one last prize I know
we've been talking about Mario just a
little bit availing a lot but I am even
more excited to let you guys know but at
LAX Mario
I need to preach you guys so you guys
want to do a photos
yeah this is the best day ever to think
you're making my dreams
happy holidays
[Applause]
pretty cool is flight ever but to make
the flight even cooler
Mario is advocate he's going to be here
ready and waiting oh my god
[Music]
you gonna take a selfie Mario because
this is very important for the social
media yeah okay okay ready
oh you don't fit in my street okay
that's good yeah
thank you so much it's him it's you
Mario oh that's so cool
this was so much fun I've also gonna put
a link in the description since we had
so much fun on this flight you guys can
actually win some really cool fun prizes
from Southwest Nintendo like in the
description check it out
[Music]